Starting with the explanation of the rules, it's
a rim for you, the newcomer of this time,
me.
Help Yes,
it doesn't matter if everyone's safety is in the middle of the quest
If even one person clears it, we can all go home
Let's conquer it with a cheap method even if it's only 1% We'll
be revived in 30 seconds
What do you do with a house?
Cutting up living meat
[Applause]
[Music]
So you don't have the luxury of worrying about the lives of characters in the game?
I have to change myself.Unlike the music girls, it's
ni After the 10th lap or after completing the practical training,
what do we like?
Start
Yoseya Yuusuke's Kozora Second Humm
's Sea It's
there because it'll come back to life in 30 seconds
.